today kiyosaki and i had a zoom we're
having a conversation we're working on
something together
and uh you know he says hey i think we
need to have this kind of podcast
together me and you this guy was i was
in the marines with him back in the days
and you know i screwed up i got kicked
out but he didn't he stayed in he became
a lieutenant general and later on became
a congressman and we both think that we
need to raise men more today et cetera
said i said
he said so how do you feel about today
with everything that's going on because
you know market crash is coming and it's
going to be very ugly uglier than what
people think is that true oh dude i'll
clear them what people think is that
right wow if you got if you
if you have the ability you're gonna buy
a lot of stocks so cheap right now did
you see plan what pallentier ceo was
talking about did you see what happened
to the valentine's stock have you seen
that or no tyler did you see what
happened to the palantir stock so first
of all that's a good stock to own it's
going to go lower okay snapchat did you
see what it dropped to in september it
was an 83 dollar stock
snapchat it's a 13 stock damn what 80
drop okay so you got every one of these
stocks you look at where they're at
right now all of them but it's gonna get
worse the next 12 to 18 months maybe 24
months to market house prices are going
to drop 20 to 40 percent when uh in the
next 12 to 24 months house price is
going to drop the next 20 20 12 to 24
months
so what do we do it's gonna happen the
people what do i do it's the people the
people that are prepared
are gonna go and add uh they're gonna
take their net worth and do five to
fifty times in the next two to five
years five to fifty times you're gonna
see guys and i'm telling you right now
you're gonna see
million dollar guys be hundred million
dollar guys the next two to five years
you're gonna see 10 million auto guys
big billionaires the next two to five
years the ones who are ready but you're
also gonna see the highly rep leveraged
200 million dollar guy become a 17
million dollar guy damn you're going to
see the highly leveraged 18 million
dollar guy become a 600 000 guy the next
uh again my opinion this is coming from
me purely as an opinion you can trash it
you can break it apart do whatever
you're doing however i thought you're
gonna be brilliant
the future looks right this is the part
this is the part of the rainbow the part
that's brought the part that's bright
unfortunately
every once in a while pruning is needed
every once in a while just like the
forest has got a lot of trees yeah
itself creates fire to
you know and then next thing you know
the ones at the bottom that are really
the ones that are going to be the
stronger powerful trees they're the ones
that needed the sun they're going to
come up and be uh better and beyond like
even right now you look at sports every
time play like look at luca lucas larry
bird but except five times better you
look a lot of these guys that are coming
up in every sport and every business and
every game podcast comedy in every way
someone's gonna come and do it better
because what they have is tens of
thousands of hours of people that did it
before them they're just going to make
it better yeah okay so but i'm
opportunity oh there's no question about
podcasting like we all everybody's like
oh yeah these liberals look look it
created an entire economy the daily wire
wouldn't exist at all you know
podcasting like people are making a
fortune
pushing back with either a
reasonableness or a right wing
when one door closes another one
by the way you know who wholeheartedly
agrees with you
uh maybe just the uh founder ceo type
guy of tesla and now twitter elon musk
you know what he i don't know if he
founded uh tesla but what did he have to
say about this he said exactly what
you're saying tyler you have that
article what was your business patrick
insurance until today i got the lauren
insurance company we have 20 000 agents
nationwide we have 150 office i'll put
an event together in august wow uh in
las vegas we'll have 15 000 people there
sebastian was the performer last year at
my annual convention
and he came up he was freaking hilarious
amazing mario lopez was our emcee you
know we had that article
but yeah
you're a guy i listen to because you're
an insurance
you're risk you're about risk purely all
insurance
elon musk knows a thing or two about the
economy well patrick what would you say
i know you guys want to get what would
you say to somebody that isn't the
millionaire it doesn't have a hundred
doesn't have 20 million let's say a
family that has let's say 20 30 000
saved what would you tell that family to
do right now
i love that great question but check
this out like like what have we valued
the last two years
how do you know
who is legit the last five years how how
the hell do you know we you know how
they say we have an economic expansion
of 128 months no we haven't we
we've had an economic expansion of
nearly 150 months 140 months take cove
it out if you took covet out and they
kept rates at zero or half a points
federal reserve this economic expansion
would have continued past february of
2020 right so what happens when the
econom economy is growing how do you
know who's a real millionaire mm-hmm
like how do you because so many people
are leveraged yeah how do you know you
don't know how do you know who's the
real comedian how do you know who's the
real there's a filtering process that we
all got to go through right that's right
okay
so the only way you know the filtering
process is during bad seasons that is
the only way you're gonna know who's
real and who's not the foundations are
stronger so so the last two years
everybody's like dude forget about just
go get your own job go to the other
companies you because i want to pay you
guys will pay 30 grand ask them for
raise if they don't leave them tell them
to work from home take them to a work
room or tell them you give them a threat
they'll have to give it to you they'll
have to keep you give all that stuff and
you know what's happened the last two
years
employers
who've been bullied are sitting there
and saying
damn
never in my life have i valued loyalty
and actually keeping your word when you
say you're gonna do something number one
more than before wow so companies are
gonna take care of those guys because
the last two years all the people that
abuse companies are getting filtered out
wow and it's going to be so freaking
awesome ugly so ugly here's another one
if you leverage too much money and you
know you shouldn't have and you were
banking on the market continuously going
up there's this thing called risk you
may have a good hit and good for you you
may make 5 10 15 20 million dollars
but if you overly leverage with the
whole thing we're talking margin call if
you overly went aggressive there's a lot
of billionaires today who were
one quarter away from being poor and
broke there's a lot of billionaires
today yeah there's a lot of billionaires
who
the market went their side they sold at
the right time they bought at the right
time they lev all the leverage at the
time you price stocks i i i've been
since 21 years old i was a stock broker
i was at bali's i was a stock broker but
you know so so today next two years
you're asking that person if you're the
person that's not the person with money
dude uh wherever you are build the
reputation of somebody that's gonna come
through
show value show loyalty show expertise
increase your skill set the market is
gonna see through the [ __ ] the next
two years i swear to god the next two
years everyone's gonna know dude
this guy's not worth 50. we got to pay
this guy 80.
you know what this advisor is not worth
the commission we're paying he deserves
more money than what he's doing with my
money because he was honest with me it
kind of come down to what we were
talking about like coming into contact
with objective reality yes right like
like that's like you other it's what i
love about fighting comedy and that is
it's really true comedy and fighting you
can't fake them you either make people
laugh or you don't when you're in a ring
and i'm watching a guy it doesn't matter
who your publicist is who your agent is
or what they say about you you either
got the goods or you're getting knocked
out and i
life business it's a scary it's that way
right oh it's a scary it's a ski but
it's again it's a scary side but it's a
great filtering site yeah and and if
you're you're good with it
you're fine
if you're prepared you're fine if you're
not
you're not but this this this next two
years two three years this two to five
year run that i'm talking about uh uh
for for you and i
we may never have another two to five
year like this i don't think its
conditions are going to be as great as
it is right now to create wealth the
next two to five years and by the way i
i'm not selling by real estate i'm not
selling buy insurance i'm not selling
anything all i'm saying is the next two
to five years there's gonna be a lot of
things for sale and everyone's all of a
sudden gonna come up the filtering
system you're going to say dude i had no
clue that that was real i had no idea
that guy was real you know the whole
thing when you said you know like uh uh
if i had a book to write a self-help
book it could be one page and the page
will be what it takes for it it takes
forever well guess what you know this
we're looking around and we're wondering
oh that guy's probably a legit guy or
that guy's probably a legit guy it's
gonna take about 20 years but it's gonna
take about 20 years for us to realize
who the real legit people are in every
field in every field in every field and
the next two to five years we're gonna
learn who actually and manage your money
one who didn't it'll create opportunity
too and fortunes are made in recessions
right all the time that's what i'm
saying please text me and brian like buy
this all the time
i love that i appreciate that that's
that's very interesting this is the
quote from us let me know if you agree
he says it's actually a good thing that
this recession that you're talking about
is going to happen it says it's a good
thing he says it's been raining money on
fools for too long and some bankruptcies
need to happen i said century i so agree
with him
i so agree with them the whole too big
to fail you know how sometimes the left
says well how about they're too big to
fail i agree yeah yeah but this time we
can't [ __ ] bail them out let them let
go
let them go a little bit let the pruning
process come let some of these guys that
are not good operators get fired
remember what shamath said about the
airport remember when when tooth when
the cove had just hit they started
bailing out all the airlines those guys
let them [ __ ] fail yeah yeah and
everyone's like what do you mean let him
fail yeah what do you mean that's that's
yeah
that's the marketplace because everyone
did their stock buybacks right before uh
after the um
trump uh
tax cut
and all these guys who had an influx of
cash all these major corporations
airlines what have you what'd they all
do they bought back stock right did you
see the credit and then they were just
not uh was solid did you see the bitcoin
thing falling and all this oh it's it's
29 by the way go back to this one a
bitcoin margin call if the world's
leading cryptocurrency drops
below twenty one thousand dollars
michael saylor's micro strategy will be
forced to pay up what does that mean
okay so uh he he bought a hundred and
seventy thousand bitcoins i believe 125
seventy thousand bitcoins
so uh michael sanders
sailor and mit grad and the co-founder
ceo of the business intelligence for
microsoft confederates ever since
company began stockpiling the
cryptocurrency in august of 2020 the ceo
has gone for uh as uh to call bitcoin
freedom as the most universally
desirable property in space and time and
in 2022 miami the largest bitcoin event
worldwide sailor was met by thousands of
cheering fans as he instructed the crowd
to never sell their crypto and look at
the dollar amount right there
3.97 billion dollars he bought 129 000
bitcoins
do you see that can you highlight that
129 by the way
he's not wrong
about bitcoin so it's not like he's
wrong about
the the technology the tech no he's not
wrong about that this guy's a
this guy's
made and lost a few times in his career
i think back in the 90s he was worth
nine billion dollars and he went back to
a billion and back up to seven billion
and back then so yeah he's he you know
you know what michael
you know michael burris
you ever watched you ever watched the
movie big short big show i read the book
good book okay so you know the guy
christian bell christian bill that's
that's a real life michael bird okay
yeah michael bury and this guy have very
similar ways of he was the guy who saw
the saw yes yeah he was the
mathematician but michael berry right
now have you seen what michael brewery
said last week did you see what michael
barry said last night you got to pull
out what michael bury said last week
michael bury is calling it it's it's uh
uh uh
okay
that one right there two days ago can
you click on it make it look big short
investor michael berry compares the
stock market slump to a plane crash and
hence troubling stocks
and home sales remind him of the housing
bubble bursting great i'm listening to
that guy well let me tell you something
right yeah you know how long he's been
saying this every freaking year since
2008
i don't know if he's been saying it's
every year since 2008 no no some of
these guys no this is how they make
their names very hard no this is do
don't don't do that because this is not
that guy michael brewery is not that guy
michael burry remember the one time joe
got upset at stephen a smith because he
was giving feedback to ufc and he's like
dude what are you doing don't do that
again and he says i will never do that
again because the guy is not from this
world this is not basketball this is not
football right joe knows the world joe
gives criticism joe has a right you
better listen to when joe says it right
because this is his world yeah michael
bury
is not a guy
but
try inviting michael berry pay him 200
grand to speak at your events see what
he'll be a disaster no no he won't take
your money because he's not that guy
yeah invite him to a podcast he'll say
no he doesn't give a [ __ ] about the
eyeballs right this isn't that wiring of
a guy this is the genius that he's got
that tourette's thing or that that that
ass person yeah he's one of those guys
so when he says that he has not been
saying this since then this is a guy
that said this in 07 06 came right and
then everything's leveled off and now
he's saying it back again but he's been
saying it adam for the last two years
but not since oh wait there's a big
difference yeah this is oh he said it in
a way for the last few years he's been
saying yeah
there's a gap of 10 years that he didn't
say it is i'm not going back
so much money in the in the quantitative
are easy
yeah just think about it this way okay
uh uh somebody does steroids and you go
out there and do
a bunch of stuff and you see a guy like
[ __ ] what happened to this guy this
guy's 160. he's at 205. i've never seen
you look like this and then you got
friends that are gradually getting
bigger and bigger and bigger and bigger
but it takes like a year two years 30
years five years okay cool but the guy
that suddenly who's not working out and
comes in and adds everything and he goes
to 205 from 160. yeah you're sitting
there saying dude the moment you can no
longer 40 grand a month or two grand a
month or you have to get off the cycle
and then your body shrinks up and you
get to the yellow skin and you look very
awkward and weird and then now you have
to get back on it or try to filter it
out of your body for six months to 12
months
america is about to go through that
phase my dad used to always call it the
difference between style and substance
it's just you know substances is the
difference you can you can dress
yourself up and look great you can act
like you're rich you can spend a lot of
money on a ferrari you can you can work
it out and have a great house but
how much money you have in the bank you
know it's the same thing and how good is
this business really are you providing
a product people actually really want to
use is it making the world better well
how's your nft collection working out
for you this this stuff never made sense
to me
i still don't know what it means i i
never i never understood did you get any
of that stuff or do you have an nf no no
you don't have like a bra but i bought
one bitcoin
just to see what was going on some
ethereum just you know i was like let me
see what happens did you hold on to it
yeah but i never i never your board ate
yacht club
working out look at it so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]